just a second here
okay I can hear you no all right so if I
look here let's say you pick up this is
a mini story in European Spanish okay so
if you save a word like Oh God oh we
identify this as a verb it tries to
identify the part of speech but
sometimes it's not accurate it's not our
algorithm but what you can do is you can
click on the verb and it takes you to
grammar explanation for Spanish verb
tenses so you know if you are dealing
with something that's in the text that
you're studying and you're curious about
the grammar you can go to this resource
the resource can also be accessed by the
grammar guide which shows up in your
profile the grammar guide for the less
the language that you're studying and
you can look up different things that
relate to grammar so that you can link
you're curious you can have a quick look
and then you should really get back to
whatever it is that you are listening to
or reading in the language so stop all
right so here I am no bit of a
disruption this morning I don't know how
much of what I said you heard if you
have any questions you can ask me but
the point I want to make is the grammar
in terms of explaining what happens in
the language is helpful but it's not a
goal in and of itself you will gradually
get better and using the language
accurately the more you listen to read
the more you speak and when you have
questions or doubts you will want to
consult a grammar quickly in and out and
you'll have to consult the same tables
and the same explanations many many
times that's been my experience with
Arabic and farsi I
starting to get the hang of you know in
Farsi they have the subjunctive so if I
want something or or whatever then it's
bad something you know whereas the
present tense is me the same in verb you
know there's stuff like that that you
start to get used to the first time it's
explained to you you don't take it in
you don't notice it but after a while
you start to notice this form of the
verb what is this form of the verb and
then you look it up and then you start
to notice it again and gradually you
start to be able to use it
Arabic is much more complicated and
sometime there's so many different
explanations that I go and look up the
information and I'm more confused so
then I just say to myself well I'm not
yet used to the language enough to be
able to absorb these explanations so
I'll go back there again and see how
much more I understand after a month or
so so to me this is this is the approach
with grammar that I take is that you
have to go to the explanations from time
to time not worry about what you don't
understand not worry about what you
can't produce when you're speaking but
regularly kind of remind yourself of
things that you may be not confident
about or you haven't noticed in the
language so that's how I approach the
issue of grammar and accuracy and they
interested in your comments so with that
let's move along
here and see what we have all right so
it's Steve doing a live stream on blah
blah blah right now hi hi folks my
learners edwin finish first remaining
today and i uses a gateway language to
slavic languages I'm not sure that
Romanian is a gateway to Slavic it's
rather if you know Slavic languages
there's about 20% of the words in
Romanian that will help you otherwise
remaining is a Romance language it's 70%
of the words are identifiable from
Italian and I think it should be learned
for its own reasons it's a very
interesting language culture and we have
some good content at link
[Music]
that sounds about right Linc's Livelink
I don't have but I'm sure you can find
her on YouTube there's no sound that no
sir yeah yeah we had that brief when the
thing went down and on Osama song ah
it was speaking a new like hey you're
right it's the lip-reading language ah
okay now all I was saying at the
beginning was that I was I was reading
from this Arabic grammar book and if
that was all missing you know some of
the explanations of birds you know if
you start with that it's so discouraging
different defective type one verb
defective type to defective type three
wha or yo as third root letter
you know the hums are here and the fatah
there it's just overwhelming and we have
to kind of get into the language get the
words kind of feeding into us try to get
some sense of the language and then we
can start looking into the grammar
that's what I was saying sure you
Spanish on link you never want to learn
Mexican Spanish would it still be useful
Oh as long as I'm also listening to
other content Mexican Spanish first of
all the continent link is the Spanish
content is from many different
spanish-speaking countries most of it is
what I would call a Latin American in
Spanish some of it is European Spanish
the differences are not great that not
even the differences in pronunciation
are that great Mexican Spanish sounds
very much like Spanish Spanish other
than the fact that they don't pronounce
the Z and the soft C with a sound but
other than that it's not that different
it's not a big deal over
the vocabulary is the same I wouldn't
worry about okay mm-hmm now turkeys
people are saying in Turkey's need to
look things up that's fine I haven't
started with turkey so I can't comment
TPR yeah total physical response I mean
these are methods in the classroom which
involves storytelling and getting people
to say things and and and getting away
again from grammar based instruction
yeah here Roman yeah it's it's sort of
living with the structures and exposing
yourself to them but in particular you
have to have some experience of the
language before the explanation of that
language may is any sense this that's
been my experience
you cannot sort of learn the language
ahead of time by looking up all the
rules will I become like the Hebrew
after Arabic and Persian it won't be my
first choice but at some point in the
future I would like to get back to
Hebrew do I come back to languages
I learned before before traveling yes
I'm gonna warm up my Ukrainian and
Russian before going to Ukraine I'm
gonna work a bit in my Korean before I
go to Japan because I'm expecting
they'll be Korean people there plus it's
a good excuse to work on my Korean well
as my I was your mother Jewish my
parents were both Jewish can you be
fluent in a language but not understand
the news or movies no if you don't
understand the news or movies I don't
think you can consider yourself fluent
I've been studying Japanese for a while
and I've gotten to the
I can enjoy our anime and dramas and
podcast but I can barely understand real
people who mumble a lot especially a
older man
well I mean you have to it whatever you
focus on if you focus on a certain type
of cut and you'll be you'll get good at
that content but if you want to be able
to understand other kinds of content you
have to expand the range of material
that you're listening to and reading I'm
learning too after once after in cases I
thought it was easy after one more
chapter everything is too confusing now
I will learn like you're reading on link
and consulting a grammar book sometimes
yeah I mean check any of the Slavic
languages is the cases I mean the
explanations are not not that you know
problematic I mean there are some funny
things like that the numbers take the
genitive or one or something is the
nominative singing or two three four is
the genitive singular and five and more
is a generally plural I mean that's
that's amazing but you first have to get
used to it all that it's fall and get in
there and then go back from time to time
and review some of these things and some
of the things you will have noticed some
of the things you will not have noticed
and the grammar explanation will will
make you more kind of aware so that's
the way to go after it and what do you
think what acceptable listen and respond
method I think the recycling moment is
over yeah I don't do a lot of responding
I don't like being you know triggered
like the Pimsleur type approach I like
getting input getting used to the
language getting as much of the language
in me as possible whenever I'm
responding you know that's a limited
amount of you know vocabulary that I can
use I like to just get it in you get it
in me at a certain point I started out
quitting you said when you learn Chinese
no car going through how's this thing
and really was the key how did you come
to that realization well I just tended
to ignore grammar explanation and I just
wanted to acquire more of the language
to learn more about China things Chinese
it just seemed to work and I realized
that you know I learned faster than the
other people and and I consumed much
much more of the language
didn't just do the textbook in the
classroom I went and found out all kinds
of material to to listen to in route and
in those days it meant readers with
glossary there was no you know internet
hell online translations and stuff been
using thing for a year for Greek that's
good I wish we had more content there
you might want to look into the sort of
automatic transcription I had to pay
people to transcribe podcasts you know I
can go to vocal Matic and there it'd be
much cheaper to transcribe podcast
okay so Peters gonna take a break from
his studies okay how are different on
Cyrillic alphabets of the Slovak
language are the similarities similar as
the English alphabet in French oh well
the only Cyrillic alphabets I am aware
of are the Ukrainian Cyrillic and the
Russian Cyrillic the Ukrainian Cyrillic
is extremely similar there's a few
there's a an eye with a dog on it and
the another eye which corresponds to the
Russian little b-flat and it's a 95% the
same as I as I see it any thoughts about
Vietnamese yeah I mean I was there I
tried to learn a bit before going there
I wasn't able to use it at all I didn't
did nothing stuck you know just look up
a phrase book before going somewhere is
is not the best way it takes a lot
actually to prepare yourself to be in a
position to actually take advantage of
being in the country that's what I can't
really with other than that I enjoyed
Vietnam very very hard-working people
very friendly and an interesting culture
why have switching dilemmas that are not
related to those who have already study
why well you know you could be more
ended motivated in different ways I was
motivated to learn more Slavic languages
because I spoke some I was motivated to
learn more Roma as languages because I
spoke some I was motivated to learn
Korean because I spoke Japanese and
Chinese but then I said I'm interested
in Arabic and so then once I had
some exposure to arabic and the arabic
writing system I said now I should take
advantage of the fact that I'm getting
used to the Arabic writing system in
order to learn Persian so different
things motivate you
salamé and my friend decided to talk it
really about topic and my friend is a
new speaker what do you think of that by
the way I'm still beginner first of all
you don't sound like a beginner but I
think that's a very good approach if you
have a language friend that's a great
thing to do
have you read the language in secret
even think her other books on language
and the brain and what good ideas have
you learned from them yeah as I remember
Steven Pinker he was a proponent of the
sort of universal grammar Noam Chomsky
which I find very difficult to believe I
don't think that's the case I think the
brain simply I read a book by Manfred
Spitzer which I've referred to before
learning and the brain or something and
it talks about how the brain will form
patterns to deal with whatever the brain
experiences in life that were constantly
learning that we have to learn we even
learn well enough to anticipate it
otherwise we couldn't get through life
and so we couldn't be dealing with every
situation as a brand new situation and
the learning of languages is simply part
of that and that the brain and I often
quote quote Manfred Spitzer who says
that we need both repetition and not
quality novelty allows us to expand our
neural networks the repetition allows
some of those neural connections to get
stronger I can't remember I'm not you
know I have a very superficial
understanding of a cognitive science how
long did it take you to create the link
my dream is to have my own English
company and teaching its different ways
do you think people who want to learn
English are used to follow yeah the
majority of people are used to the
normal chapter one chapter two chapter
three learn this learn that the murderer
is passive the teacher runs it that's
the normal approach based on my language
learning experience we developed a
different thing at link we've been at it
for about 10-12 years
so Edwin is saying I should slow down
okay I will slow down I always thought I
could never know but now I will have
money to stay motivated yes
learning turkey is now a moderate
learned Kazakh great sigh you know I
have a lot of trouble reading Arabic on
the fly I study for about an hour a day
using Lync is that enough I mean
whatever you do is enough as much time
as you can find or want to spend it's
all good yeah do I think it's useful to
write kanji by hand that's how I learned
them but I don't know if it's necessary
because there are other approaches now
to learning kanji that didn't exist when
I was learning kanji so that's all I can
say there okay hi science song I think
today whether any tips to learn German
please brother
to learn German there are no I mean
there are no real tips for any language
every language has its peculiar features
and we have to get used to them and and
we get used to them by exposing our
brains to the language through listening
and reading and occasionally looking up
some explanations maybe starting out
with a bit of an overview and then going
back to the grammar explanations from
time to time but mostly listening and
reading when I stopped trying to
memorize the declension tables in German
that's when my German started to improve
so don't try to master the rules of
German grammar try to expose yourself to
as much reading and listening I find
people don't listen enough yeah do you
think English will keep its position as
an international language in the future
yes I don't see that changing it's just
too convenient if a person from Kuwait
travels to Japan they're going to speak
the people are gonna communicate in
English it's there it's available it's
convenient I think possibly that
regional languages may become more
important so you know if again presume
that Ahmed is is an arabic-speaking
country so as I understand that like not
even Fattah is a common language amongst
Arabs they speak their own version of it
or they speak French sure they speak
English but maybe Arabic Spanish Russian
Portuguese Malaysian Indonesian Turkish
these are languages that are regional
and importance they made increasing
importance I don't know Gus said I tried
to speak Greek everyone answered in
English I got a lot of people speaking
to me in Greek work on the many stories
it'll get your everyday language up to a
level where more people will humor you
what do you think of Aida Xhosa nests
and his mimic method I have no idea I
don't know what it is that's where I
fail with speech I didn't listen enough
and have a hard time understanding
Swedish speakers yeah it's kind of
pointless to be able to speak if you
don't understand what people are saying
back to you and whenever I review
people's profiles statistics here people
ask me to review their statistics people
don't listen enough you have to listen
more and when you listen you notice the
things that you don't understand and
then you should go and read it and then
go back and listen again and certainly
in the case of the mini stories I've
listened to 10 15 20 times you gradually
listen less and less often but listening
is my is 75 percent of what I do in
language er yeah I agree with Roman he's
better to listen to concentrate and find
every time I listen I can notice
something that I didn't notice the
previous time whereas when you're
speaking you're you're kind of using the
limited vocabulary that you have
so I prefer to wait until I'm better I'm
sorry you're speaking what is the most
important thing in speaking except words
the most important thing in speaking is
not to worry about it it's just to speak
whatever words you're able to find use
them and then just continue your input
activity so that you become more and
more comfortable with the language
Michel Thomas I'm not a fan because I'm
not a fan of listening to any language
other than the target language I don't
like that's the big problem I have with
the newer versions of teach yourself and
colloquial there's simply too much
images and the Pimsleur is the same way
and Michel Thomas is that way too I'd
like to hear the target language and
then read it what do you do if you get
stuck in the intermediate level of
language you just keep going the
intermediate level is a good place to be
because you can use the language to
learn a lot of stuff and to enjoy the
language movies reading travel and
eventually you will improve how much the
hours we show how much okay as much as
you can how much should I listen today
as much as you can as much as you can't
fit it in five minutes here 10 minutes
there wherever you can listen mm-hmm
okay
he likes learning the etymology of the
kanji I have never done that and I have
it's an interesting thing to do but it I
have not found that it helped me learn
because the quality of candy that we
have to learn is so great and the number
of words formed with this country so if
I were to spend my time studying the
etymology of individual kanji it's not
something I would miss at them you know
I got mighty kind of assist others
myself okay
trying to duck should master grammar up
front is not only not something that I
don't recommend it's not something I
recommend it's something that isn't
possible until you have had enough
exposure to the language you will not
master the grammar upfront I
don't know where we are on ty Gary I
have to say I will have to check I don't
know if there are people working on mini
stories in my ideas combination
listening and reading movies with cells
so the brain combines the picture with
the Sun fine okay you know I think we're
gonna stop it here
two in a row is a lot for me and I think
I'm gonna go and have another cup of
coffee so thank you and sorry for the
disruption I don't know what happened
Google came in and insisted that I can
reconfirm my signature one last question
here the most difficult thing when you
study new language there is no one thing
it's all fuzzy all foggy and you just
simply have to keep going okay bye for
now